If you thought Mondays were depressing, you're
absolutely right.
Science has proven it.
Hey guys Tara here for Dnews - with some harrowing
facts about suicide.
A new study published in the Journal of Emergency
Medicine, finds that certain seasons, holidays,
and days of the week are associated with a
higher number of suicide attempts.
Poisoning is currently the #1 most common
method of attempted suicide in the U.S.
So for this study, researchers examined over
a million calls classified as ''suspected
suicides" by the National Poison Database
System between 2006 and 2010.
The results showed that the beginning of the
week, along with spring and fall, and New
Year's Day - were all associated with higher
numbers of ingestions with suicidal intent.
For adults, Sundays and Mondays were the two
most common days of the week, while those
age 19 and under saw the biggest peak on Mondays
and Tuesdays.
As for seasons, research has previously shown
that spring carries a higher number of attempted
suicides, but this study also found a correlation
between fall - noting significantly more attempted
suicides in those two seasons, than in the
summer and winter.
New Year's Day also had a higher number of
incidents than any other holiday, with the
lowest amount occurring on Independence Day,
Thanksgiving, and Christmas.
It's unclear why more people attempt suicide
during these times, but one explanation offered
by the doctor who conducted this study, says
it's possible that people associate these
times with new beginnings, "but become disappointed
when their life circumstances remain unchanged."
She also found that nearly two-thirds of individuals
who commit suicide had contact with a physician
in the month before their death, while 43%
had been seen in an emergency department sometime
in the year before their death.
This ties in with the fact that patients experiencing
suicidal thoughts on a Sunday, or on holidays
like New Year's Day, may have limited access
to doctors.
And it further highlights the need for a 24-hour
help hotline, along with 24-hour clinics.
It's pertinent to mention here that if you
or someone you know is experiencing suicidal
thoughts, there is a place to get help.
Several, in fact.
The National Suicide Prevention Lifeline is
open 24 hours a day, 7 days a week - and they
always have someone willing to listen and
talk.
(800-273-TALK)
Thanks for watching, and for more episodes
of Dnews - subscribe here.